et tout de suite en direct de can nous
recevons Lars venter et Bjork bonsoir à
tous les deux Lars vreir can vous aime
et vous le montre c'est la troisème fois
que vous êtes primé après le grand prix
du jury pour Breaking the wave voici la
palme d'or alors tout de suite votre
état d'esprit votre émotion qui était
évidemment visible sur la
scène oui je voudrais dire c'est c'est
c'est merveilleux je ne peux je ne peux
rien dire de plus je commence à aimer
les
Français je je commence à les aimer je
dois vous l'avouer alors cette fois-ci
vous aviez accepté de de venir à Cann
contrairement à la dernière fois vous
aviez envie de de défendre
personnellement ce film qui qui vous
tient particulièrement à
cœur et bien l'histoire sera très très
ennuyeuse à propos de ce que je peux ou
ne peux pas faire mais cette fois-ci
j'ai pris beaucoup
de médicaments et l'usine qui fabrique
du valium me vend beaucoup qu'avez-vous
envie de dire à Bor qui est à vos côté
ce
soir vous
m'entendez est-ce que vous
m'entendez je je vous demandais
avez-vous envie de dire à
borou je vous
entends c'est
privé j'ai beaucoup
ch chaque fois je lui dis quelque chose
de gentil cro
pas dire quelque chose de
gentil que voudrais-tu dire si tua juste
à côté de toi que
diraistu je suis
reconnaissante je te suis reconnaissante
L
donc c'était privé très très
agréable bien nous fer un bon couple
dans 10 20 ans vous nous reverrez tant
mieux parce que peut-être que le
tournage a été parfois difficile je
voudrais surtout m'adresser maintenant à
Bork bonsoir je sais que jusqu'à présent
vous avz choisi de vous taire et c'est
donc un privilège de vous avoir ce soir
dans quel état d'esprit quelle émotion
êtes-vous
actuellementô je crois que je me sens un
peu comme quelqu'un qui est en visite
parce que j'ai fait de la musique
pendant si longtemps et j'ai
l'impression d'être une mouche sur le
mur et qui observe th
à fa intér et je suis très honoré
d'avoir été accueilli si
merveilleusement et je suis un petit peu
timide mais très très
heureuse et je serais heureuse de
pouvoir boire un verre de champagne
après on va sûrement vous l'offrir mais
reste encore avec nous simplement
quelques instants à qui avez-vous envie
de dédier cette récompense ce
soir B est-ce que vous
m'entendez oui je vous entends je
voudrais
dire que cette victoire va également à
yoga et Andrea s'il n'avait pas été avec
moi je n'aurais sans doute pas terminé
le film Bork vous avez pris pendant le
tournage votre rôle très à cœur est-ce
que cela été une souffrance pour vous
une souffrance que vous avez ressenti
qui a fait un tournage parfois difficile
et bien je jouais en fait deux rôles je
faisais la bande musicale c'était très
instinctif pour moi je fais cela depuis
si longtemps et c'était un défi et tout
à fait passionnant et
c'était un côté artisanal il y avait
l'autre côté de moi qui était de faire
l'actrice pour la première fois et comme
a été dit dans la presse par lar et
moi-même la seule façon de le faire
c'est qu'il y a 2 ans j'ai remis mon
corps et mon âme entre les mains de
cette femme du N de
Salma
et cellule par cellule je suis devenue
elle et donc il y a eu tout ce processus
qui était en fait un processus d'abandon
c'est ce que souhaitait également Lars
c'était pas le fait de jouer donc
maintenant euh nous avons terminé le
film et petit à petit mon corps revient
cellule par cellule à devenir à être
biork
et je souhaiterais vous annoncer que je
suis revenu à l'ancienne Bork et je suis
ravie d'être de retour et j'en suis très
reconnaissante Pascal Deschamp qui est à
vos
côté Pascal moi je voulais de poser
poser une question à à Lars vonre votre
film c'est une tragédie musicale on l'a
vu c'est une centrale nucléire d'émotion
il y a énormément de de de virtuosité
technique c'est aussi on va le dire une
charge politique une charge contre la
peine de mort à la sortie de la salle
pour la projection officielle il y avait
des centaines de paquets de de clleinex
vid comme ça alors quel trace
voulez-vous laisser dans l'esprit du
spectateur est-ce que l'émotion peut
permettre au spectateur d'accéder à une
une
vérité
bien je n'ai pas vraiment de de
recettees s'agissant des émotions je ne
peux faire que faire des films pour
moi-même et si cela accroche avec un
public et ben tant mieux je m'en
félicite si vous pensez que ça peut vous
aider à pleurer bien
faites-le merci à à nos deux invités